a lot of tributes to Coby tonight in
there tell me about them it's beautiful
you did that for me it's a big night in
LA also the jerseys are out how're you
gonna watch it and what do you think
about that tribute there's more than
well deserved and I know he's loved by
Lakers and Laker nation
I wouldn't expect nothing from Jamie bus
and women Aramis in the Laker
organization one of my favorite moments
always that I will never forget is after
that first championship you two coming
in to the locker room afterwards NBA
said no interviews you dragged them in
there with you
you hugged them and you said this is my
brother always tough
you know it's tough because we won't get
their hackles these conversations yeah I
don't even want to have these
conversations with other people when I
have it with him when I go to his Hall
of Fame on to say congratulations when I
go to his statue unveiling I want to say
congratulations next time I see him I
want him to go I got five you got four
next time I see him I'm gonna go oh my
go to 15 go to 15 so just you know as
well as you see them to do very well
here tonight I'm gonna just take care of
both homeless and we also need to up the
conversation about them to go bgg of
course they're important but everybody's
important so I'm knocking boas goes out
to all the other come we're sorry I
don't have the manage memorize but I
have the pictures actually have it up on
my wall so from those as to all the
families we're gonna be hurting for a
long time yes as I said on TV I have
been going right into it no it's just
about you know when you work as hard as
I do if I would do certain things you
miss certain things that just Michelle's
anything you say my last thing or two
guys in
last time I saw him was the Laker of the
tio2 sit-down interview
I made a mistake I thought the last time
I saw him was in the last game just
because I remember how great he was at
that game I thought that was the last
time but the last time was when we did
that sit-down interview that's probably
one of the best things ever
no we yeah when people look at it you
can place they took me clear there was
more air to clear you Big Brother little
brother I have a little brother and we
fight all the time
I got sisters we fight all the time me
and Barker fall out of time man Kevin
Frazier fought one no seriously because
he said something I didn't like I
approached him like a man he explained
and I said you know what Kevin you're
right that's what men do you know your
total problems on all this you know
people want everything to be peachy and
creamy nothing in real life if it was
real life I'd buy the program and master
it and never have a problem with anybody
but you know the key thing was respected
and we were on three out of four and
whatever will forever be linked Seco but
you got to say chef you say Shaq you
guys said coke I just wish that he was
here to see it with us we all good man
we will never let us never never never
never ever let him be forgotten was
already a martyr and kids kids kids kids
kids kids kids kids kids will know
for the Graco before I was you got an
Italian those two little baby always
listen babies they don't call me uncle
Shack for reason you called me up you
find me I'm not hard to find
I do whatever y'all need
[Music]